voyons maintenant l'état d'esprit d'une
famille appartenant au camp des
défenseurs de l'école publique les
chauffeurs sont laïques de père en fils
ils vivent à goussainville dans le val
d'oise et demain ils défileront pour
défendre leur conception de la laïcité
eric domage etc le du sud
l'appel à la manifestation demain
on a un rendez vous donc à la gare
principale de pouce habitat départ
roger sheff les militants et comme aux
grandes heures de campagne
il fait le marché comme disent les
militants à goussainville val d'oise il
n'ya pas d'écoles privées pas trop de
danger penseront certains mais ce n'est
pas forcément ceux là qui anime ses
adhérents de la fcpe ses trois filles
sont dans le public lui est un enfant de
la communale l'école pour lui revêt un
aspect bien plus grand que le simple
apprentissage de l'alphabet c'est une
représentation miniature de l'avif
on a différentes races qui sont mélangés
différentes philosophies qui sont
pratiqués par les inclinaisons et il ya
un respect une tolérance de ces
différentes aspirations philosophique
religieuse à l'intérieur de l'école de
filles en primaire une au collège la
famille schaeffler à une nette
préférence et elle n'affiche cependant
le transfère vers l'école privée se fait
très souvent à l'entrée au lycée ou en
cas de problème mais d'ici on croit dur
comme fer à l'école de jules ferry
ça m'a même pas effleuré l'esprit qu'il
est que je mette mes enfants dans
l'école privée
s'il ya un échec scolaire il me semble
qu'il ya différentes dispositions dans
l'école publique pour essayer de faire
face à cet échec scolaire et en dernier
mois on fait plutôt plutôt que de parler
d'échec scolaire on parle plutôt de
l'école de la réussite
demain on défilera en famille non pas en
protestant contre une loi annulés depuis
mais en montrant une volonté pour
l'école publique qui si on ne s'affiche
pas anti privé ou anticlérical la
famille schaeffler et chrétienne défis
vont au catéchisme
le choix de l'école ici est une question
de philosophie mais aussi de moyens